each present alloys today we present the
newest member of BMWs X family from the
front it strongly echoes the x3 and
guess what the technology is based on
the x3 as well but from the back it's a
coupe a like the BMW x6 and price and
features though it's more like an x5 so
the BMW x4 isn't really an SUV but as a
sea or sports activity coupe a let's see
what i can do is 4runner the x6 caused a
stir when it appeared many thought it
looked too massive but the car sold well
its concept has now been adapted for the
smaller x4 together with the grand coupe
a it completes the car makers for series
it's aimed at SUV drivers who want to
stand out from the crowd
this is none given BMW's Richard Jacoby
says it's a car for SUV drivers in the
premium mid-range class who are looking
for a special performance and unique
design look up button on the outside the
x4 is brawny and confident from the side
it recalls the silhouette of the x6
there's a new double creasing over the
rear wheel cargo space ranges from 500
to 1400 leaders inside like all for a
series models its high quality and
elegant while still offering a touch of
sportiness the rear bench is spacious
enough for longer trips the BMX fears
and back the x4 is designed as a 2 plus
1 seat a bit tight for the one in the
middle but behind the driver sasha has
enough space for his knees and more
importantly despite the coop a roof
enough Headroom to look but in reverse
the coop a shape does cause problems
looking through the back window you see
practically nothing but the car offers
two possibilities in Reverse there's the
360-degree overhead view or a rear view
camera in law school the basic version
with the engine we tested can be have
for 58 thousand euros in Germany but our
model had every available extra feature
raising the price to a lofty 78,000
euros
Thanks few is Richard Jacoby says the
x-force technology is based on the x3
but it puts a greater emphasis on
performance and design it's a lifestyle
car a new take on BMWs familiar x6
concept you don't miss become conceptus
Austin bin vixx together with its
siblings the x3 x5 and x6 the x4 is
built in BMW Spartanburg South Carolina
plant north america is one of its main
sails markets with global demand for the
x models undiminished BMW is investing a
billion dollars in the facility within
two years annual production capacity
will expand by fifty percent from
300,000 units to 450,000 about seventy
percent of the cars built here are
exported throughout the globe de
pestilence Richard Jacoby explains the
price difference between the x3 and x4
the x4 has much more generous standard
features basically all the x3 zonal
sports and performance features are
standard on the x 4 features formics
daya Enix fear Celia likes performance
control sports steering link sports
leather steering wheel with paddles it's
even and sports automatic transmission
to the x4 also has rear assistant
parking in Celia an automatic rear hatch
standard size and the most markets sent
on headlights and 18-inch wheels the x4
is just as happy on trails and unpaved
roads as on the highway as the same
off-road specs as the x3 BMW sees its
customers mainly in the US and China but
Germany and Italy have enough interested
buyers to
for desirable that in Sasha's opinion
the x4 is too classy for those kinds of
surfaces and at seventy eight thousand
euros it's also quite expensive
visibility in back is limited but the
car is a real looker
hasta que te as mother says the VW polo
has his GTI version and the ds3 has its
racing the sports car variant of sit
wins compact model and now there's a
limited edition of 100 convertibles it's
not a full convertible as the side rails
remain in place when the roofs down but
then you can also open it when zipping
along and then it's time for fun in the
Sun hardly any of its competitors offers
a convertible version let alone with
this kind of performance the ds3
Racing's 1.6 liter engine can harness
152 kilowatts of power that takes this
little rocket from 0 to 100 in just six
and a half seconds top speed is 235
kilometers an hour
the ds3 racing may be fast but is it
also fast on the curves the potentials
there but you need a steady hand
puzzle to montes reminds us of a problem
with all-powerful front wheel drive cars
including the ds3 racing when you really
step on the gas the engine has a
powerful effect on steering it's not
nearly as nice as in an all-wheel drive
or a rear-wheel drive car so much behind
a modified oder einem hakan good evening
out or what certainly is nice is the
exterior the ds3 which also works in the
ragtop version although the ds3 is known
for its customizing options the racing
version is available only in the mat
moon dark body colour
plenty of carbon defines the Racing's
look one quirky trait is the cargo hatch
then month elanco monta says when you
returned from shopping having left the
roof open and want to stow your purchase
you'll need patience first the roof has
to shift upwards and then you can open
the hatch conestee klappa ethelyn the
ds3 convertible offers 245 liters of
cargo space but loading isn't simple
because all you've got is a cramped and
impractical opening but back to the roof
for the better the closer before going
shopping anyway if only for Security's
sake the completely open roof also has
its disadvantages think visibility
then munda stopped when the roof is down
the rear view mirror is blocked even if
you turn around you can't see much but
the generous side mirrors and big
windows do help the fence tough lesson
on defect line and us problem and taking
curves you should be looking forward
anyway my country roads the ds3 turns
into a little power pack that keeps its
driver comfortable he's it's like a farm
episode Martha says he especially likes
the seating he's well positioned with
good lateral support beside bolsters
aren't too stiff and give a little if
you're a bit wider in the waist the only
thing that could be bigger is the actual
seat it's a bit short city sits Felicia
does as hell atif cuts inside we find
reflections of the exterior color scheme
again lots of carbon
and the racing is especially pretty when
you let it sing
hear that it's the sound of excitement
and when the roofs down you hear it even
more the racing takes its name seriously
it accelerates fast breaks fast takes
curves well and it's fun when shifting
if it only weren't for that stiff
steering during fast curves
ah so fast but ds3 racing convertible is
definitely a fun car but personally
Montes wouldn't pay such a high price
for a car in which the fun factor far
outweighs the practical side 38,000 490
euros in Germany isn't exactly spare
change but perhaps the idea of being one
of only 100 is compensation and the
enjoyment factor could clinch the deal
so if you like muscle design and
exclusivity he might just fall for the
ds3 racing
670 exhibitors from 44 countries came to
Essen for the reifen the world's leading
tyre fair to present their newest
products this year's hot topic was tire
pressure control systems starting
November first they'll be mandatory on
new cars in the EU the regular valve is
replaced by this orange one a sensor and
it passes the data to an on-board
computer on this prototype the sensor is
vulcanized straight into the rubber at
the factory this tire has twice the
running surface but less rolling
friction it's not likely to go into
production but it might inspire further
innovation the rims too are writing the
Green Wave a mineral based material is
used wherever metal isn't absolutely
necessary that makes the rims much
lighter
over 60,000 people converged on the
motor sport arena and oschersleben when
a 2014 opal meet fans united under the
lightning bolt logo the owners polish
and buff until they're darlings dazzle
but clean here is a different kind of
clean when tuners say a car is clean
they mean free of what they see as
needless gizmos and gadgets even under
the hood lots of ice mountain powell is
a noble tuner he says as long as the
weather is nice the washer system can go
he'll wipe the windshield himself he can
even do without the power steering and
many other trifles as he calls them as
an excit kyden other owners like to add
features on or alter what's their rear
hinged doors and a whiskey lounge on the
back seat even matching slippers some
local drivers compete to see how low
they can get their skirts hemlines
Marco rota puts lots of work into his
car too much he says he spent every
winter for 10 years tinkering with it
fans of the man to be like to call it
the bricklayers portion they show lots
of ingenuity in their alterations a
sunroof that can be stowed in the trunk
if desired and as a highlight rear
hinged doors the Skip saw Audrey genie
says this is one of a kind he's never
seen another one like it this omega is
another rarity it was a diplomat's car
custom built with six doors other tuners
copied the idea only six of the six door
versions were sold in Germany and a few
more modified versions in Britain but
this particular car is a real original
opel limousine the hulk of all opals
history is also on show time-honored
names from ships and the sea like the
capitaine Commodore and cadet the fans
at the meet are every bit as diverse as
the cars
the noobs India should vanish Erna has
been coming for years he says there's
always a few live wires here but that's
part of the fun he's always amazed at
the money the young owners put into
their cars the way they preen and gleam
and clean and polish their cars is a
site in itself of movement led him on
through this lens about keeping in touch
with its customers opal has brought the
fastest aster of the current generation
to the meet the extreme with bucket
seats and lots of carbon fiber this
prototype is the dream of many an opal
driver the constables young Schwartz
says the mint is an ideal platform for
communicating with fans he's here to
offer them a chance to take the OPC
around the track a Driver Safety Center
is standing by they're interested in the
car makers commitment to motor sports or
at least and the party afterwards with
friends he's glad everything's running
smoothly that's all business part if I
admitted Freud this one's in its echo
Christopher Jennings had a dream come
true he got to ride shotgun in a real
Astro race car with pro driver yo ahkam
vinca hook who demonstrated how fast you
can go on the ushers laban track /
vinkel hook it's always interesting to
see the passengers different reactions
they have little experience with actual
racing
he says some are delighted others get
very quiet it's fun for him to watch
people experience what it's really like
inside a race car when it's not just
going for a pleasant spin it's hard
physical work that varies according to
the track and the car but most people
are thrilled and it's a fun experience
this must be avoided or knocked out one
Christophe says it was amazing to see
what a professional race car driver can
get out of it he almost thought they'd
lose control a couple of times but
you're welcome big hug tamed the Beast
his fast-breaking was also impressive do
you have spunk did you spittin finish
behind the moment then Christophe takes
the car around the track on his own the
experience only reinforces his feelings
I'm once with opal always with opal
Mercedes presents the new heavy haulage
version of the actress the actress SLT
it's a truck with big ambitions a robust
high-tech vehicle with a pulling weight
limit of 250 tons imma to be sure they
are Stas kovitch former Sadie says the
new lense LT is part of the recent
revamp of the Actros serials the heavy
haulage truck is designed to comply with
the Euro 6 emission standards meeting
those standards meant making some
changes to the engine so Mercedes
decided to rethink the entire series on
denim brakes discuss the concept of our
budget and this is the result but
designing a new heavyweight truck is a
complex matter the pasando in Douglas
odd for Mercedes explains why the SOT
was designed to handle very large loads
and that required some special steps a
heavy haulage vehicle can't be tested on
ordinary roads because they have a 44
ton weight limit so Mercedes needed a
special testing ground to put the truck
through its paces and Mercedes wanted
real live customer feedback after all
this truck is a working vehicle to
decide to move heavy goods and
construction machinery Mercedes ask
clients in Switzerland and Germany and
put their feedback into the new design
that was a key part of the design
process of killing my own funding
couldn't become Davido imbalance in the
end i clienti frozens in this is intense
Mystica aspect in design victim the
reason
truck driver hanazawa gets behind the
wheel to check it all out it's a monster
with a 460 kilowatt engine with a torque
output of 3000 Newton meters it's all
powered by a 15.6 liter v6 engine but
vow is an old hand and he knows how to
tame the Beast laFonda anna says the
truck does a fantastic job in terms of
economics the layout is the same as in
the rest of the new actros line the
shift lever is positioned on the
steering wheel and is easily accessible
to the dashboard and instrument layout
is excellent so for the driver it's just
about perfect from Attila know you got
tied up the wolf endure osmond disease
dr. Mudd the cab is generously
proportioned with well over two metres
of headroom
when does journalists PR cut cenar
agrees the first thing you notice is
it's roominess there's plenty of room to
stand materials and workmanship are
excellent too and the longer layover
spending a few hours in the cab is no
problem it's comfortable it's almost
homey and really quite impressive that's
it's like a fine Holton's this grill
behind the cab hides the cooling tower
it's positioned so that even at low
speeds the truck won't draw in exhaust
air the driver can tilt the cab at the
push of a button the cooling tower stays
in position the 16 speed automatic
transmission and the turbo retarder
clutch are also technical standouts
deepest and low on today it's odd
explains that when it comes to heavy
haulage trucks the two challenges are
starting up and maneuvering that means
you want a turbo retarder clutch it
fills with oil when you need full power
the fluid can be cooled which is the
real advantage the heat has generated is
then discharged through the cooling unit
mapa fuel
the hops was once the truck is under way
the regular dry clutch comes into action
then the actress drives like a regular
truck with a regular transmission midna
mama tried katiba
does the senior driver hanas valises you
really notice the difference starting up
a heavy truck like this requires a great
deal of power with the turbo clutch you
can even start the actress on a slope
without rolling backwards once the truck
is moving the turbo clutch is switched
off the truck switches to a conventional
friction clutch so there's little
slippage that also helps lower fuel
consumption a bit and once you're on the
road the fully automatic 16 speed
transmission it makes for a very smooth
ride Nesmith on design yousafzai stinkin
cattiva at my 90 Magnum tomorrow
Huntress you know Richard cylinder in
both comfort and performance the Actros
SLT is the perfect beast of burden
the two friends even Charu at Rafael
sawaya have just arrived in Sao Paulo
Brazil in their 1967 VW busca Portuguese
for beetle they've covered it with the
very same slogans they had on their old
61 beetle when they drove it to the
world cup in mexico 44 years ago back
then it took them 22 days non-stop to
reach Mexico City but they were there
watching brazil win the championship
title the young men partied together
with their star players until dawn those
aren't the only memories they brought
back
no today no RPL remembers Pele's
impressive headers amazingly loud it was
louder than Rafael could shoot with his
feet no beru let me know impress your
nut we decided to repeat their adventure
for this year's World Cup with any luck
they'll be cheering their team on to the
title that would be perfect and this
time it would be even in their home
country
of the moon Raphael explains that
everyone wanted to hear their stories
from their first trip but they hadn't
taken any pictures I've never wrote a
book so they decided to relive their
experience and catch it on camera so
this time their friends and family will
be able to share in the fun and one time
the streets of Brazil were teeming with
millions of VW beetles in the 1950s they
were everywhere here and everyone wanted
one soccer star Pele had a whole garage
full the tournament is Apollo the the
best scorer in the league the ways they
get a box fan that that as a price now I
was four or five times not the best
squad oh the the the the the selection
the collections of of folks I the beetle
is still a cold car in Brazil weather
tuned or factory original low-riding or
classic the Brazilians love their
bug-eyed bug dark busca vintage car fans
get together and collectors clubs all
across the country
this is l for tomorrow this fusca fan
agrees Brazil is wild about the beetle
maybe it's the shape that's so appealing
it's a real eye catcher even young
people love the beach you don't disabled
disabled' of Gotham I Spit engine
something special that's exactly what
Raphael and Yvonne are hoping for to
another chance to cheer on their team
and to celebrate another world cup
victory like their beetle real Brazilian
soccer fans keep going and going and
going